[Applaudissements]
le directeur général de W9 vient
d'annoncer une nouvelle qui risque de
mettre les fans de télé-réalité pls nous
ne lancerons pas une nouvelle saison des
Marseillais
[Musique]
les Marseillais disparaissent de la
grille des programmes de W9 l'année
prochaine alors est-ce la fin de la
télé-réalité
alors je veux dire et moi il y en a
plein que je kiffe moi dans le terrain
pas gage j'adore il est très sympathique
j'adore Jessica Julien c'est vrai Maëva
voilà Jérémy apparemment c'est c'est la
fin gilberté
aussi on vieillit son passé à autre
chose alors les premiers rôles les
premières stars n'ont pas été
renouvelées et d'autre part la star acte
leur a mis quand même un sacré coup
parce que la star ACA ringardisé les
Marseillais et les programmes de
téléréalité qui existent avec son esprit
bon enfant des nouvelles figures donc
moi je pense que c'est vraiment fini il
y a eu trop de bad buzz du harcèlement
des problèmes donc c'est téléréalité là
pour moi elle est morte qui pense que
c'est pas fini Béatrice ah oui parce que
c'est son anniversaire celle-là est
finie mais j'avais pas compris la
question
c'est un problème avec
vous voulez rentrer tout de suite vous
souhaitez votre anniversaire
ce type de téléréalité oui après la
téléréalité va se réinventer ils vont
trouver des nouveaux concepts et donc
voilà
Monsieur
il y a moins de 10 ans ça faisait encore
un million téléspectateurs aujourd'hui
ils sont péniblement 400 500000 le
problème c'est que je me rappelle
pendant le confinement il faisait 1
million 2 bah ouais Apple ou pas Mathieu
bien sûr
pas si longtemps et le problème c'est
que dans cette télé-réalité il y a plus
aucune réalité les candidats ils sont
failles qui jouent la comédie ils se
mettent en couple uniquement pour
exister dans l'émission il y avait des
pseudos enjeux professionnels
aujourd'hui on sait que c'est bidon et
les télé-réalités les divertissements
qui marchent aujourd'hui c'est les
divertissements avec de l'enjeu comme la
Star Academy Mario premier regard avec
un peu dangereux L'Amour est dans le pré
il y a de l'enjeu là malheureusement
c'est un peu trop light un peu trop vite
donc c'était les réalités là ouais je
pense qu'elle est morte malheureusement
merci en tout cas vous êtes toujours là
pour pousser vos petits camarades qui a
été non mais castanique je passe le
précurseur je m'étonne que c'est duré
aussi longtemps déjà je pense que
franchement depuis le début ils offrent
une télé qui est tout sauf elle en fait
tout tout est pivoter on leur dit de
faire ci de faire ça donc je vais te
dire que c'est marcher aussi longtemps
en revanche c'est une bonne nouvelle
pour la télé d'enfermement à mon avis
qui va revenir les îles pour une fois il
a pas complètement tort c'est de les
mettre les enfermés dans les containers
une maison et c'est vrai que de les voir
enfermées sans moyen de communication
entre eux et en fait l'un des moteurs de
territorité c'est en fait c'est l'ennui
plus il s'ennuie et plus il fait de
choses ça c'est pas comme ça mais c'est
comme ça donc je pense que ça peut
donner un coup de boost effectivement ou
alors un retour on en parle beaucoup de
big brothers version originale je vous
rappelle de l'émission de base story ça
veut dire non non en fait Big Brother
qui n'a jamais été fait en France en
version originale on en parle comme un
essai en français en fait c'est la base
c'est toujours un peu parti de vos infos
vraies alors je m'étais je m'étais un
peu planté sur Amazon Prime mais moi je
pense que c'était à l'heure oui par TF1
paraît-il avoir non mais Big Brother
pourrait revenir
beaucoup la télévision canadienne la
télévision
qui a relancé la croisade et puis
c'était enfin voilà qui a pensé et Big
Brother cartonne là-bas en ce moment
avec des personnalité ça marche très
très fort et effectivement il paraît
qu'ils sont en train de regarder pour
relancer balle en fait c'est toujours
pareil c'est back to basic à un moment
donné 20 ans après tu reviens
mais je n'y crois pas mais le problème
on verra c'est M6 en fait en France
c'est que ça marchera jamais tu sais
pourquoi parce qu'en France on est
muselé et là-bas il y a beaucoup plus de
liberté en France tu ne pourras jamais
passer un Big Brother comme tu le vois
en équipe mais jamais de la vie c'est
impossible mais pas à la télé en fait
c'est ils mettent des gens dedans mais
avec un peu du Koh-Lanta c'est à dire
qu'il y a des il y a des épreuves à
faire chaque jour à l'intérieur pour
gagner des choses c'est ce qu'ils ont
essayé de faire dans les 50
M6 voulait relancer soit secret soit le
loft ils ont fêté les 15 ans de secret
sur TFX ça a pas marché donc là il se
chauffe plutôt sur le loft comme la star
qui a marché sur TF1 ils aimerait
relancer le Story sur M6 très bien merci
que la sociologie des casting va changer
la Star Ac c'est bien parce que les gens
ils sont les jeunes les jeunes gens sont
normaux en fait c'est des normaux donc à
la méritocratie il y a le travail à la
discipline et c'est des bonnes valeurs
positives et je pense que c'est casting
comme ça avec les esthétiques
pornographiques où toutes les filles
sont refaites au tous les mecs sont des
mêmes corps les mêmes tatouages les
mêmes trucs et tout je pense que c'est
fini c'est un mauvais exemple pour la
jeunesse et on est arrivé au bout du
bout du bout du système et c'est tant
mieux alors on va voir ce qu'on pensait
les spectateurs à 19h20 23 voilà 83 % 94
même non c'est fini pour eux voilà ils
sont d'accord avec avec vous